[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you win the top extra spicy that's 20
cents more are you up for nothing you
two get back to work for Christ's sake
well that'll uh that will do it for the
24-hour KOCO cam
thanks guys it's been really fun you
guys have all been awesome we want to
thank all of our awesome interns our
great staff here costume a Scott chronic
did our digital team everybody did a
great job we want to thank you the fans
you guys have been really great thank
you for sticking with us please watch
our show November 8th on TBS and what
else please follow us team koco.com
and yes this has been an awesome great
experience we hope you enjoyed it
sorry for any crazy downtime at 5:00 in
the morning we were a little crazy but
it was really fun I have exactly 30
seconds left
team koco.com if you'd like to vote for
our first guest we are doing that at
Team Coco calm / first guest poll so
please go and vote the power is in your
hands who's going to be our first guest
our first show November 8 it's up to you
I know it's crazy that's the way the
internet works
it's a beautiful amazing system look for
recaps on our youtube channel
youtube.com slash team cocoa for
everything that's happened in the last
24 hours
and we will see you guys later thanks a
lot
[Applause]
you
you